the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT opencourseware continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
as I said my name is Ken Abbott I am the
operating officer for firm risk
management at Morgan Stanley which means
I'm the everything else guy I'm like the
the normal stuff with a borrower the
complement of normal I get all the odd
stuff uh I consider myself the Harvey
Keitel uh character you know the fixer
uh
and so I get a lot of interesting stuff
to do I've covered Commodities I've
covered fixed income I've covered
equities I've covered creditors I've
covered mortgages now I'm also the chief
risk officer for the buy side at Morgan
Stanley the investment management
business and and the the private Equity
Holdings that we have uh and uh I look
after a lot of that stuff and I sit on
probably 40 different committees because
it's become very very very bureaucratic
but that's that's the way it goes
um what I want to talk about today is
some of the core approaches we use to
measure risk in a market risk setting
this is part of a a larger course I
teach in a couple places uh I'm a I'm a
triple Alum at NY NYU no I'm a double
Alum and now I'm on the faculty in
different school I have a masters in in
economics from their uh Arts and
Sciences program I have a master's in
statistics from Stern when Stern used to
have a stat program and now I teach at
currant
um I also teach at Claremont and I teach
at Baruch part of that program so I've
been through this material many times so
what I want to do is lay the foundation
for this this notion that we call Value
risk this this idea of VAR
foreign
I got it I'll make it work uh
talk about it from a mathematical
standpoint and from a statistical
standpoint but also give you some of the
intuition behind what it is that we're
trying to do when we measure this thing
um first a couple words about risk
management
what is it that risk do 25 years ago uh
maybe three firms had risk management
groups I was part of the first first
Management Group at Bankers Trust in
1986 1986 all right no one else had a
risk management group as far as I know
risk management really came to be our
Market risk management really came to be
in the uh in the late 80s credit risk
management had obviously been around at
in large financial institutions the
whole time so our job is to make sure
that management knows what's on the
books so Step One is what is the risk
profile of the firm how do I make sure
that management is informed about this
so it requires two things one I have to
know what the risk profile is because I
have to know it in order to be able to
communicate it but the second thing
equally importantly particularly
important for you guys
and girls
is that you you need to be able to
express
relatively complex Concepts in simple
words and pretty pictures all right
chances are if you go to work for a big
firm
your boss won't be a Quant
my boss happens to have a degree from
Carnegie Mellon he can count to 11 with
his shoes on all right his boss is a
lawyer his boss is the chairman all
right
commonly the most senior people are very
very intelligent very very articulate
very very
learned but not necessarily quants many
of them have had a year or two of
calculus maybe even linear algebra but
you can't count you can't show them look
when when you and I chat we talk about
regression analysis I could say x
transpose X inverse X transpose Y and
those of you taking a regression course
think ah
that's beta hat and we don't we could
just stop it there I could just put this
form up there and and you may recognize
it I'd have to spend 45 minutes
explaining this to people on the top
floor because this is not what they're
studying in so we can talk the code
amongst ourselves
but when we go outside our little group
getting bigger uh we have to make sure
that we can express ourselves clearly
that's done in clear effective pros and
in graphs and I'll show you some of that
stuff as we go on so step one make sure
management knows what this profile is
step two protect the firm against
unacceptably large concentrations this
is the subjective part I can know the
risk but how big is big
how much is too much how much is too
concentrated if I have a million dollars
of sensitivity per basis point that's a
100 the one percent move in a rate is
that big is that small
how do I know how much how much of a
particular stock issue should I own how
much of a bond issue how much of a
Futures open it how much Futures open
interest how big a limit should I have
in this type of risk that's where
intuition and experience come into play
so that's the second part of our job is
to protect against unacceptably large
losses
so third
no surprises
you can liken the trading business it's
taking calculated risks sometimes
sometimes you're going to lose many
times you're going to lose if in fact if
you win 50 point percent of the time
life's pretty good all right so what you
want to do is make sure you have the
right information so you can estimate if
things get bad how bad will they get
and to use that we leverage a lot of
relatively relatively simple uh Notions
that we see in statistics and so
I should use a coloring mask here not
the spotlight we do a couple things just
like the way when they talk about the
press in in your course about journalism
we can shine a light anywhere we want
and we do all the time you know what I'm
going to think about this particular
kind of risk I'm going to point out that
this is really important you need to pay
attention to it and then I can shade it
I can make it blue I can make it red I
can make it green I could say this is
good this is bad this is too big this is
too small this is perfectly fine so
that's just a little bit of quick
background on what we do
all right
so I'm going to go through as much of
this as I can uh
I'm gonna fly through the first part I'm
going to hit these because these are the
ways that we
we actually estimate risk variance
covariance is a quadratic form Monte
Carlo simulation the way I'll show you
is based on a quadratic form and
historical simulation is Monte Carlo
simulation without the Monte Carlo part
it's it's using historical data and I'll
go through that fairly quickly questions
comments
no
excellent stop me if I say look if any
one of you doesn't understand something
I say probably many of you don't
understand it I I don't know you guys so
I don't know what you know what you
don't know so if there's a term that
comes up you're not sure just say can
and it's Ken I I don't have a PhD I I
work for a living
I make fun of academics you'll have to I
know you work for a living too all right
there's a guy I tease at Claremont I I
in this class I said who has this point
to hit an academic fur to know that
only kid all right so
all right so I'm going to talk about one
asset value risk first I'm going to
introduce the notion value risk I'm
going to talk about one asset we call
that price-based instruments we're going
to go into into yield space so we talk
about the conversions we have to do
there uh one thing I will do after this
class is over since I know I'm going to
fly through some material and since this
is MIT I'm sure you're used to just
flying through material and there's a
lot of this the proof of which is left
to the reader as an exercise I'm sure
you get a fair amount of that I will
give you papers if you have questions my
email is on the first page
I welcome your questions I tell my
students that every year I'm okay with
you sending me an email asking me for a
reference on a citation something I'm
perfectly fine with that don't don't
worry oh he's too busy I'm fine just you
got a question something's not clear uh
I've got access to
thousands of papers and I've screened
them I've read thousands of papers say
you know this is a good one that's a
waste of time but I can I can give you
background material on regulation not
Bond pricing on derivative algorithms
let me know I'm happy to provide that at
any point in time you get that free with
your tuition
all right
um a couple of key metrics I don't spend
too much time on this interest rate
exposure how how sensitive am I to
changes in its rates Equity exposure
commodity exposure credit spread
exposure we'll talk about uh linearity
we'll talk about we won't talk too much
about regularity of cash flows we won't
really get into that here and we need to
know correlation across different asset
classes and I'll show you what that
means
all right
at the heart of this notion of value at
risk is this idea of a statistical order
statistic who here has heard of order
statistics
all right I want to give you 30 seconds
the best the best simple description of
an or of an order statistic
for the minimum of a set of observations
all right
when we talk about value at risk
I want to know the worst one percent of
the outcomes
and why do we do what's cool about order
statistics is they're well established
in the literature
pretty well understood all right and so
every people are familiar with once we
once we we put our toe into the academic
water and we start talking about this
notion there's a vast body of literature
that says this is how this thing is this
is how it behaves this is how what the
distribution looks like and and so we we
can we can estimate these things
um
and so what we're looking at invite risk
if
my distribution of returns how much I
make all right on it in particular if I
look historically I have a position how
much would this position have earned me
over the last n days and weeks and
months
if I look at a frequency distribution of
that
I'm likely don't have to I'm likely to
get something that's symmetric I'm
likely to get something that's unimodal
all right uh it may or may not have fat
tails we'll talk about that a little
later
if my return distribution were
beautifully symmetric and beautifully
normal and and independent then
the risk I could measure this one
percent order statistic what's what's
the one percent likely worst case
outcome tomorrow
all right I might do that by integrating
the normal function from negative
Infinity
for all intents and purposes five or six
standard deviations anyway from negative
Infinity
to negative 2.33 standard deviations why
because the area under the curve that's
.01 now this is a one-sided confidence
interval as opposed to a two-sided
confidence interval and this is one of
these things that as an undergrad you
learn two-sided and then the first time
somebody shows you one side like wait a
minute what is what is this then oh I
get it you're just looking at this area
I could build a gazillion two-sided
confidence intervals one-sided it's got
to stop at one place all right so this
set of outcomes and this is standardized
it says in standard deviation space
all right
negative Infinity to 2.33 if I want 95
percent or five percent likely loss so I
can say tomorrow there's a five percent
chance my loss is going to be X or
greater I would go to 1.645 standard
deviations
because the integral from negative
Infinity to 1.645 standard deviations is
about
0.9 is about 0.05 it's not just a good
idea it's the law
all right does that make sense
so and again I'm going to say assuming
the normal that's like the old Economist
joke assume a can opener when he's on
the desert island you guys don't know
that one I got lots of Economics jokes
I'll tell them later on maybe or after
class
um
if I'm assuming a normal distribution
and that's what I'm going to do what I
want to do is I'm going to set this
thing up
in a normal distribution framework now
doing this approach and assuming normal
distributions I I liken it to to using
Latin
nobody really uses it anymore all right
but everything we do is based upon it
and so that's our starting point and
it's it's really easy to teach it this
way and then we relax the assumptions
like so many things in life I teach you
the strict case and we relax the
assumptions to get to to the way it's
done now all right so this makes sense
all right so let's get there
this is an old way oversimplified but
let's say I have something like this
who's taking intermediate statistics
all right
we have a notion of stationarity all
right uh that we talk about all the time
uh the mean and variance constant is one
simplistic way of thinking about this do
you have a better way for me to put that
to them because you know what their
background would be no that's cool all
right just the meaning variants are
constant a
when I look at the time series itself
the time series mean and the time series
variants are not constant all right this
is and there also could be other time
series stuff going on there could be
seasonality that could be
autocorrelation
um but this looks something like a
random walk
but it's not stationary
all right it's hard for me to draw
inference by looking at that alone so if
I want to try to predict what's going to
happen in the future it's kind of hard
and the game here that we're playing is
we want to know how much money do I need
to hold
to support that position now who here's
taking an accounting course
all right
word to the white there's two things I
tell students in Quant Finance programs
first of all I know you have to take a
Time series course I'm sure it's MIT
right
uh if you don't get a Time series course
get your money back because you got you
got to take Time series
accounting is important
accounting is important because so much
of what we do the way we think about
things is predicated on the dollars and
you need to know how the dollars are
recorded
quick aside
balance sheet I'll give you a 30 second
accounting lecture
assets
what we own
all right everything we own we have
stuff it's assets
we came to that stuff one of two ways we
had paid for it out of our pocket or we
borrowed money there's no Third Way so
everything we own
we there paid for out of our pocket or
borrowed money the amount we the amount
we paid for out of our pocket
is the equity
the ratio of this to this is called
Leverage among other things
all right
if I'm this company I have this much
stuff
and I bought it with this much debt and
this much equity and again that's a
gross over simplification
when this gets down to zero it's game
over belly up all right
does that make sense let's see now
you're taking a semester of accounting
you know no only kidding uh
but uh it's actually important to have a
grip on how hey on how that works
because what we need to make sure of is
if we're going to take this position and
hold it we didn't make sure that with
some level of certainty
every time we lose money this gets
reduced when this goes down to zero I go
bankrupt all right so that's that's what
we're trying to do we need to protect
this
and we do it by knowing how much this
can move against us
everybody with me anybody not with me
it's okay to have questions really it is
all right so if I do a frequency
distribution of of this time series
all right I just say show me the
frequency with which this thing shows up
I get this thing it's
it's kind of trimodal it's all over the
place it doesn't tell me anything if I
look at the levels the frequency
distribution the relative frequency
distribution of the levels themselves I
don't get a whole lot of intuition if I
go into return space which is either
looking at the log differences from day
to day or the percentage changes from
day to day or perhaps the absolute
changes from day to day varies from
Market to Market all right
oh look now we're in familiar territory
so what I'm doing here and this is why I
started out with the normal distribution
because this thing's unimodal
it's more or less symmetric right now is
it a perfect measure no because it's
it's probably got fat tail so it's a
little bit like looking for the glasses
you lost up on 67th Street down on 59th
street because it's more light there but
it's a starting point
so what I'm saying to you is once once I
difference it all right uh like the the
no we'll talk about arima uh one side
difference the time series Once I once I
take the time series and look at the
percentage changes and I look at the
frequency distribution of those changes
now get this
Which is far more amenable and I can I
can draw inference from that I can say
ah now if this thing's normal then I
know that X percent
of my observations will take place over
here now I can start drawing inference
all right and I think keep in mind here
one thing we do constantly
in in statistics is is we make
we do parameter estimates all right and
remember every time you estimate
something you estimate it with error I
think that may be the single most
important thing I learned when I got my
statistics degree everything you
estimate you estimate with that people
do means they say oh the it's x no
that's the average and that's an
unbiased estimator but guess what
there's a huge amount of noise and
there's a certain probability that
you're wrong by X percent so every time
we come up with a number
and when somebody tells me the risk is
10 that means it's probably not 10 000
it's probably not zero
keep that in mind just sort of throw
that in on the side for nothing all
right so when I take the returns of this
same time series I get something that's
unimodal symmetric may or may not have
fat tails that has important
implications for whether or not my
normal distribution underestimates the
amount of risk I'm taking
everybody with me on that more or less
questions now would be the time
it might be good enough
he's lived this all right
all right so once I have my once I have
my time series of returns which I just
plotted there I can gauge their
dispersion with this measure called
variance
and you guys probably know this
all right
variance
expected value of x i minus X bar I love
these thick chalks
squared and it's the sum of x i minus X
bar
squared over n minus 1. all right it's a
measure of dispersion all right uh
variance has it went now
I should say that this is a
Sigma squared
all right you guys right estimate
parameter estimate parameter
parameter estimate all right this is
measured with error
anybody here know what the distribution
of this is
anyone five dollars
close
and chi-squared for two dollars talk to
me for class
it's a chi-square distribution now what
does that mean that means that
all right we know it can't be zero or
less than zero if you figure out a way
to get variances less than zero let's
talk all right uh it's got a long right
tail but that's because this is squared
my Intuit then that one one point can
move it up anyway so I have this once I
have my returns I have a measure of the
dispersion of these returns called
variance all right I take the square
root of the variance which is the
standard deviation or the volatility
um when I'm doing it with a data set I
usually refer to it as the standard
deviation when I'm referring to
the the standard deviation of the
distribution I usually call it the
standard error that just is that a law
or is that just common parlance
I can ask
whereas the standard deviation is more
like for a sample see this is this it's
important because when you first learn
this they don't tell you that and they
they flip them back and forth and then
when you take the intermediate courses
they say no you got don't use standard
deviation when you mean standard error
right and you'll get points off on your
exam for that right
all right so uh standard deviation
validating uh is is the square root of
the variance also called the volatility
in a normal distribution one percent of
the observations is outside of 2.3
standard deviations in uh for 95 percent
it's out past 1.64 1.645
standard deviations now you're saying
wait a minute where's my 1.96 go that I
learned as an undergrad two-sided
so if I go from the mean to 1.96
standard deviations on either side that
encompasses 95 of the total area of the
integral from negative Infinity to
positive Infinity everybody with me on
that does that make sense
the two-sided versus one-sided that's
confused me when I was your age it
confused me a lot but I got there all
right
all right so this is how we do it uh uh
Excel functions are VAR and say you
don't need to know that all right so in
this case I estimated the variance of
this particular time series I took the
standard deviation if I take a square
root of the variance
um it's in percentages when you do this
it's like physics your units will screw
you up every time all right what am I
measuring what are my units what I I
still make units mistakes I want you to
know that I'm in this business 30 years
I still make units mistakes just like
physics all right I mean percentage
change space so I want to talk in terms
of percentage changes the standard
deviation is 1.8 percent of that time
series I showed you so 2.33 standard
deviations times the standard deviation
is about 4.2 percent
what that says given this data set
One Time series
I am making the I am saying I expect to
lose on any given day if I have that
position
99 of the time I'm going to lose
4.2 percent of it or less
very important think about that is that
clear
that's how I get there I'm making an I'm
making a statement about the the
probability of loss I'm saying there's a
one percent probability if I for that
particular time series which is
all right
if I if I if this is my historical data
set and it's my only historical data set
and I own this
tomorrow
I may be 4.2 percent lighter than I was
today because the market could move
against me and I'm 99 sure if the
Futures like the past
that my loss tomorrow is going to be 4.2
percent or less
that's far
simple simplest case assuming normal
distribution single asset
not fixed income
yes no questions comments
yes yes assuming my distribution is
symmetric
now that's that's this is where
this is where I that's the right
assumption to point out because in the
real world it may not be symmetric and
when when we go into historical
simulation we use empirical
distributions where we don't care if
they're symmetric because we're only
looking at the downside
and whether I'm long or short
I might care about the downside or the
positive upside
because I'm short I care about how much
is going to move up makes sense that's
the right question to ask
yes
uh if you're doing it for upside as well
yes it would just be the same thing yes
in fact in this case in what we're doing
here a variance covariance or closed
form bar it's for long or short
but getting your signs right
telling you say physics I still make
that mistake I still make that mistake
yes
symmetry do you guys still use this
process to say okay I use it all the
time as as a heuristic
all right because I let's say I've got
and that's a very good question uh let's
say I've got you know the five years
worth of data and I don't have I don't
have time to do an empirical estimate it
could be lopside it could be crazy all
right if you tell me uh two standard
deviation move is X
that means something to me now
there's a problem with that and the
problem is that people extrapolate that
people sometimes people talk to me oh it
was an eight standard deviation move
eight standard deviation moves don't
happen I I don't think we've seen an
eight standard deviation move in the
cenozoic era all right all right it just
doesn't it just doesn't happen
um three standard deviation was you
you'll see a three standard deviation
move
once every ten thousand observations
I learned this the hard way by just see
how many how many times do I have to do
this and then I looked it up on the
table oh okay I was right but so when we
put when people when we oversimplify and
start talking about everything in terms
of that normal distribution we really
lose our grip on reality but I use it as
a heuristic all the time a lot I'll do
it even now and I know better but I'll
go what's two standard deviations what's
three standard deviations because by and
large
and I still I still do this I get my
data
uh and I line it up and I do frequency
distributions
hold on I do
I do this all the time with my data
is it symmetric is it fat tail is it is
it unimodal so that's a very good
question
any questions
uh we introduced it in the last lecture
um and the problem set this week does
relate to that
all right perfect leading
so the statement I made is one percent
of the time I'd expect to lose more than
4.2 pesos on 100 peso position
all right that's that's what my that's
my my state my inferential statement
in fact over the same time period
I lost 4.2 percent
one and a half percent of the time
instead of one percent of the time
what that tells me what that suggests to
me is my data set has fat tails what
that means is the likelihood of a loss
a simple way of thinking about it I'm
going to be careful between what that
means in a metaphysical sense for the a
way to interpret it the likelihood of a
loss is greater than would be implied by
the normal distribution all right so
when you hear people say fat tails
generally
generally that's what they're talking
there are different ways you can
interpret that statement but when
somebody when somebody's talking about a
financial Time series
it has fat tails three quarters roughly
three quarters of your financial time
series I have fat tails they'll also
have time series properties they won't
be true random walks a true random walk
says that I don't know whether it's
going to go up or down based on the data
I have it's the the time Series has no
memory
when we start introducing time series
properties which many Financial time
series have all right then there's
seasonality
there's mean reversion there's all kinds
of other stuff other ways that we have
to think about modeling the data
make sense
as a highest and division then we
calculate say it once again
not better
no the standard deviation is the
standard deviation
all right that's no matter what I do
this is this is you know standard
deviation
that's it don't have a higher standard
deviation
all right but the likelihood of the put
it this way the likelihood
of of a move
of 2.33 standard deviations
is more than one percent that's the way
that's the way I would that's the way I
think of it
makes sense
yes
sorry is there any way for you to like
graph what a fatter tail looks like oh
well if we even we have time in fact we
do that all the time and one of our
techniques doesn't care it goes to the
empirical distribution so it captures
the fat tails completely
in fact one of the homework assignment
which I you usually precede this lecture
by has people graphing all kinds of
distributions to see what these things
look like
we won't have time for that but I'll
I'll see if I if you have questions send
them to me I'll send some stuff to read
about this
all right so now you know one asset far
now you're qualified to go work for a
big Bank
all right
get your data calculate returns now I
usually put in Step 2B
graph your data and look at it
all right because everybody's data has
dirt in it everybody's they don't trust
anyone else if you're gonna get fired
get fired for being incompetent don't
get fired for using someone else's bad
data all right don't trust anyone You My
Mother gives me data Mom I'm graphing it
because I think you let some poop slip
into my data all right
all right Mother Teresa could come to me
with a thumb drive Ken
s p 500.
sorry Mother Teresa I'm graphing it
before I use it
all right so I I don't want to say that
this is usually in here we do extensive
error testing because it it there could
be bad data there could be missing data
and missing data is a whole other
lecture that I give you might be shocked
at how no
um all right so for one asset bar get my
data get my create my return series
percentage changes log changes sometimes
absolute differences take the variance
take the square to the variance multiply
by 2.33 done and dust it go home take
your shoes off relax
okay percentage changes versus log
changes
for all intents and purposes
it doesn't really matter and I will
often use one or the other
um way I think about this
all right there'll be a little bit of
bias at the ends but for the
overwhelming bulk of the observations
whether you use percentage changes or
log changes doesn't matter
generally even though even though I know
the data is closer to log normally
distributed than normally distributed
I'll use percentage changes just because
it's easier
uh why would we use log normal
distribution well
when we're doing simulation the log
normal distribution has this very Nifty
property of keeping your your yields
from going negative
all right but even that is I can call
that into question because there there
are instances of yields going negative
all right it's happened doesn't happen a
lot but it happens all right so talk
about bad data talk about one-sided
versus two-sided I'll talk about Longs
and shorts a little bit later when we're
talking multi-asset
um
I'm going to cover the fixed income
piece
we use this thing called a pv01 because
what I measure in fixed income markets
isn't a price as you measure yield I
have to get from a change of yield to a
change of price
sounds like a Jacobian right what's kind
of a poor man's Jacobian all right it's
it's a it's a measure that captures the
fact that my price yield relationship
all right price yield
is non-linear for any small
approximation
I look at the tangent all right and I
use my PV of one
which has a similar notion of to
duration but pv1 is a little more
practical all right the slope of that
tells me how much my price will change
for a given change of yield see there it
is you knew you were going to use the
calculus right you're always using the
calculus you can't escape it all right
but the price yield line is non-linear
but for all intents and purposes what
I'm doing is I'm shifting in the price
yield relationship I'm shifting my yield
change into price change by multiplying
my yield change by my pbo1
my which is my price sensitivity to a 1
100th percent move in yields
think about that for a second we don't
have time I would love to spend an hour
on this and about trading strategies
about both deepeners and bear steepeners
and and barbell trades but we don't have
time for that suffice to say if I'm
measuring yields
all right the thing's going to trade as
a 789 or a 622 or a 401 yield all right
how do I get that into changing price
because I can't tell my boss hey I had a
good day I I bought it at 402 and sold
it at the 401. no how much money did you
make yield the coffee break yield to
lunch time yield to go home at the end
of the day all right how do I get from
changing yield to change in price
usually pbr1 I could use duration
Bond traders who think in terms of the
coffee break at lunchtime you have to go
home at the end of the day typically
think in terms of preview one do you
agree with that statement
did you how often on the fixed income
desk did you use duration measures
when because the investor Horizon yeah
okay the insurance companies
very important point I want to race here
is a quick aside you're going to hear
this notion of pv1 which is called PVP
or db01
that's the price sensitivity to a one
base Point move one basis point is one
100th a percent in yield
all right duration measure is the
half-life essentially of my cash flow
what's the what's the weighted expected
time to all my cash flows if my duration
is 7.9 years my pbo1 is probably about
790 per million all right in terms of
significant digits they're roughly the
same but they have different meanings
and the units are different duration is
measured in yield pvo1 is measured in in
dollars all right in in bond space I
typically think in pbo1 if I'm selling
to long-term investors they have
particular demands because they've got
cash flow payments they have to hedge so
they may think of in terms of duration
for our purposes we're talking
dvo1 or pvo1 or pvbp those three terms
more or less equal
make sense yes
we could in some in some instances in
some areas and options we might look at
an overall one percent move but we have
to look at what trades in the market
what trades in the market is the yield
all right when we quote the yield I'm
going to quote it going from 702 to 701
I'm not going to have the calculator
handy to say a 702 move to a 701 what's
702 minus 701 divided by 702 you know it
makes sense it's the path of least
resistance all right what's in between a
bond and a bond Trader a bond matures
little fixed income humor therefore
apparently very little
all right
all right
I don't want to spend too much time on
this because we just don't have the time
um I provide an example here if you guys
want examples
contact me I'll send you the
spreadsheets I use for other classes if
you just want to play around with it
um
when I talk about pv01
when I talk about yields I usually have
some kind of risk-free rate although
this whole notion of the risk-free rate
which is so much of modern Finance is
predicated on this assumption that there
is a risk-free rate which used to be
considered the US Treasury used to be
considered risk-free well there's a
credit spread out there for U.S treasury
there's just I don't mean to throw a
monkey wrench into the works but there's
no such thing I'm not going to question
75 years of academic Finance but it's
Troublesome just like when I was taking
economics 30 years ago
inflation just mucked with everything
all the models fell apart they were they
were there were appendices to every
chapter on how you have to change this
model to address inflation and then
inflation went away and everything was
better but this may not go away I've got
two components here if the yield is six
percent
I might have a 450
treasury rate and 150 basis point credit
spread the credit spread reflects the
probability of default and I don't want
to get into measures of risk neutrality
here
but I have to pay if I'm an issuer and
and I have a chance to default I have to
pay my investors more all right
usually the sensitivity
uh is measured to
the
measure system we talk about that credit
spreads intensity and the the risk-free
sensitivity you say well how could they
possibly be different and I don't want
to get into detail here but the notion
is when when credit spreads start
getting high it implies a probability of
default a higher probability of default
um when you have to think about credit
spreads to say a little differently
because when you get to a thousand basis
points 1500 base points credit spread
it's a high probability of default and
your credit models will think
differently your credit models will say
ah that means I'm not going to get my
next few payments there's an expected
there's a probability default there's a
loss given default and there's recovery
a bunch of other stochastic measures
come into play I don't want to spend any
more time on it because it's just going
to confuse you now
suffice to say we have these yields and
yields composed are composed of risk
free rates and credit spreads all right
and I apologize for rushing through that
but we don't have time to do it
all right
typically I have more than one asset so
in this framework
where I take 2.33 standard deviations
times my dollar investment or my renmin
B investment or my Sterling investment
all right
um that example is with one asset if I
want to expand this and I can expand
this
using
this notion of covariance correlation
you guys covered correlation and
covariance at some point in your careers
yes no all right
both of them measure the way an asset
moves when asset moves vis-a-vis another
asset
correlation is scaled between negative
one and positive one
all right so I think of correlation as
an index of linearity
covariance is not scaled I'll give you
an example of the difference in
covariance and correlation what if I
have 50 years of data on crop yields
and that same 50 years of data on tons
of fertilizer used
I would expect a positive correlation
between tons of fertilizers used and
crop yields
so the correlation would exist between
negative one and positive one
the covariance could be any number and
that covariance will change depending on
whether I measure my fertilizer in tons
or in pounds or in ounces
all right or in kilos
the correlation will always be exactly
the same the linear relationship is
captured by the correlation
all right but the units in covariance
the units count
all right if I have covariance
it's uh there it is
covariance matrices are symmetric
they have the variance
along the diagonal and the covariances
on the off diagonal which is to say that
the variance is the covariance of an
item with itself
all right the correlation Matrix also
symmetric is the same thing scaled all
right
with correlations where the the diagonal
is 1.0
if I have covariance because correlation
is covariance
sorry
covariance divided by the product of the
standard deviations
gets me Co sorry
correlation here all right
uh this is like the the the apostrophe
in French you'll forget it all the time
but the one time you really need it
you won't do it you'll be in trouble all
right
um if you have the covariances you can
get to the correlations if you have the
correlations you can't get to the
covariances unless you know the
variances That's a classic midterm
question I I give that almost in not
every year maybe every other year
all right don't have time to spend much
more time on it suffice to say this
measure of covariance it says when X is
a certain distance from its mean how far
is y from its mean and in what direction
yes
now this is just a little empirical
stuff because I'm not as clever as you
guys
and I don't trust anyone I read it in
textbook I don't trust anyone all right
a b here's a plus b so I just look
variance of a plus b is variance of a
plus variance B plus two times
covariance a b it's not just a good idea
it's the law I saw it in a thousand
statistics textbooks I tested it anyway
because if I want to get fired I'm going
to get fired from making my own mistake
not making someone else's mistake I do
this all the time and I just prove it
empirically here
the proof of which will be left to the
reader as an exercise
I hated books said that
should never trust you know output from
computer programs or packages or your
mother or Mother Teresa
check all the calculations all right
Mother Teresa will slip you some bad
data if she can I'm telling you she will
she tricky that way all right don't
trust anyone I've caught mistakes in
software
all right I had to program my one of my
favorite stories
all right we're talking about we're
doing one of our first Monte Carlo
simulations and we're factoring a matrix
and we're going to get into it we have
time again so I factor a covariance
matrix
into uh
uh e-transpose Lambda e it's our front
in the quadratic form we're going to see
this again all right
and this is a diagonal matrix of
eigenvalues and I could take the square
root of that so this I can say this is e
transpose Lambda to the one half Lambda
to the one half
e and so my programmer had gotten this
and I said do me a favor I said take
this and transpose it multiply by itself
so take the square root and multiply it
by the other square root and show me
that you get this just show me he said I
got it I said you got it he said at the
16 decimals
I said stop
on my block
the square root of 2 times the square
root of 2.
equals 2.0
all right
2.000
what do you mean out to 16 decimal
places what planet are you on
and we I scratch a surface and I dug and
I asked a bunch of questions
and it turned out in his code he was
passing a float to a fixed
all right
don't trust anyone's software check it
yourself
all right that just
someday when I'm dead and you guys are
in my position you'll be thanking me for
that
all right put a stone on My Grave or
something
all right
um all right so covariance covariance
tells me some measure of when X moves
how far does y for any other asset could
I have a piece of your cookie I've
already had lunch you won't even have
pieces right
it's just looking very good there hey
it's foraging I'm convinced that 10 10
million years ago my ape ancestors were
the first one at the dead antelope on
the planes all right
all right
don't talk about colonization and
covariance
covariance is not unit free
I can use either but I have to make sure
I get my units right you need to screw
up every time they still screw me up
let's go to cooking
all right
all right some more facts
variance of XA times YB x squared irons
variance a y squared variance B plus two
x y covariance a b you guys seen this
before I assume you have
all right
and I can get pretty silly with this if
I want
x a y b z c w you get the picture right
but what you should be thinking
if this is a coverage Matrix
Sigma squared Sigma squared Sigma
squared all right
the sum of the variances plus two times
the sum of the covariances so if I have
one unit of every asset and I've got n
assets all I have to do to get the
portfolio variance
is sum up the whole covariance Matrix
now you never get only one unit but just
saying but you notice that this this is
kind of a regular pattern
that we see here
and so what I can do is I can use a
combination of my correlation Matrix
and a little bit of linear algebra
Ledger domain
all right to do some very convenient
calculations and here I just give an
example of a covariance matrix and a
correlation Matrix note the correlation
Matrix is between negative one and
positive one
all right
let me cut to the chase here
here I'll draw it here because I really
want to get into some of the other stuff
what this means
if I have a covariance structure
Sigma
and I have a vector of positions X
dollars and dollar Yen y dollars in gold
Z dollars in oil
all right and let's say I've got a
position vector
that's One X two
x three
x to the n
all right
all right
if I have all my positions recorded as a
vector this is asset one as a two and
this is in dollars
all right and I have the covariance
structure
the variance
of this portfolio that has these assets
and this covalent structure this is
where the magic happens all right
these X transpose
Sigma X
all right
equals
Sigma squared hat
portfolio
now you really could go work for a bank
this is how portfolio variance
using the variance covariance method is
done
in fact when we were doing it this way
20 years ago
spreadsheets only had 256 columns
so we tried to simplify everything into
two or sometimes you had to sum it up
using two two different spreadsheets we
didn't have multi-tab multitab
spreadsheets that was a that was a dream
multi-tab spreadsheet this was this was
Lotus one two three we're talking about
here okay you guys don't even know what
Lotus one two three is it's like it's
like an abacus but on the screen yes
position Vector let's say I tell you
that you've got Dalian golden oil you
got a hundred dollars a dollar yen
fifty dollars of oil and 25 of gold all
right it'd be a hundred fifty twenty
five now I should say if it's a hundred
dollars a dollar yen
your position Vector would actually show
up as negative 150 25. why is that
because if I if I'm measuring my dollar
yen
and this is just a little aside
um
typically I measure dollar yen in Yen
per dollar
all right so Dalian might be 95.
if I own Yin and Yen and I'm a dollar
investor and I own Yen and Yen go from
95 per dollar to 100 per dollar do I
make her lose money
I lose money negative 100. and that's
save that for just store that
you won't you won't be tested on that
but just we think about that all the
time same thing with yields typically
when I record my pvo one and I'll record
some versions something like my pv01 in
that Vector my interest rate sensitivity
I'm going to record it as a negative
because when yields go up and I own the
bond I lose money
signs very important
so and again we've covered usually I do
this in in a two hour lecture and we've
covered it in less than an hour this is
pretty good all right
um I spend a lot more time on the fixed
income are you taking something for that
that does not sound healthy
I don't mean to embarrass you but I just
want to make sure that you're taking
care of yourself because grad students
don't
I was a grad student I didn't take care
of myself very well I worry
all right
um
big picture variance covariance collect
data calculate returns test the data
Matrix Construction
get my position vector
multiply my matrices
all right quick and dirty
that's how we do it that's the
simplified approach to measuring this
order statistic
called value at risk using this
particular technique
questions comments
anyone
anything you think I need to elucidate
on that
and this is in fact how we did this up
until the late 90s
all right firms use variance covariance
I heard a statistic in in Europe in in
1996 that 80 of the European Banks were
using this technique to do their value
at risk there's no more complicated than
this
I used a little flow diagram
get your data returns graph your data to
make sure you don't screw it up
uh get your covariance Matrix
multiplier matrices at next transpose
Sigma X
using the position vectors and then you
can do your analysis normally I would
spend some more time on that bottom row
and different things you can do with it
but that suffice the the that'll have
its device for now
a couple points I want to make before we
move on about the assumptions
to worry about where I'm actually I'll
fly through this year so we can get into
Monte Carlo simulation
um where am I going to get my data where
do I get my data I often get I get a lot
of my data from Bloomberg I get it from
public sources I get it from the
internet especially when you get look if
it says so on the internet it must be
true right
didn't Abe Lincoln say don't re don't uh
believe everything you read on the
internet that was a quote I saw that
someplace
um all right you get data from people
you check it all right there are some
sources that are very reliable if you're
looking for yield data or foreign
exchange data the Federal Reserve has it
and they have it back 20 years daily
data it's the h15 and the h10
all right
uh it's it's there it's free it's easy
to download just be aware of it Exchange
a steady posted on the website that goes
through uh calculations computations for
regression analysis and asset pricing
models and the data that's used there is
from the Federal Reserved for yields
it's probably from the age 15. those
files you'll see how to actually get
that data for yourselves now
another great source of data is
Bloomberg
now the good thing about Bloomberg data
is everybody uses it so it's clean
relatively clean I still find errors in
it from time to time but what happens is
when you find an error in your Bloomberg
data you get on a phone to Bloomberg
right away and say I found an error in
your data they said what date June 14th
you know uh 2012 and they'll say okay
we'll fix it
all right so everybody does that and the
data set's pretty clean I I found
consistently that that Bloomberg data is
the cleanest
in my experience
how much data do we use in doing this I
could use one-year data I could use two
weeks of data now time series we usually
want 100 observations that's always been
my my rule of thumb
but I could use one year of data our
Regulators require use at least a year
of data you could use two years of data
in fact some firms use one-year data
there's one firm that uses five years of
data
in doing their respect and and there we
could say well am I going to wait am I
going to weight my more recent data
heavily I could do that with a with an
exponential smoothing which we won't
have time to talk about it's a technique
I can use to to lend more Credence to
the more recent data now
I'm a relatively simple guy I use tend
to use equally weighted data because I
believe in Occam's razor which is the
simplest explanation is usually the best
um I think we get too clever by half
when we try to parameterize you know how
fast is my memory
the how how much more does last week's
data have an impact then from two weeks
ago three weeks ago I'm not saying that
it doesn't I'm not what I am saying is
I'm not smart enough to know exactly how
much it does that's and assuming that
everything's equally weighted throughout
time is just a strong assumption
all right but it's a very simple
assumption I love simple
all right just yes
yes
all right quickly
actually I think I have some slides on
that
let me just finish this now I'll get to
that all right uh gaps in data missing
data is a problem how do I fill in
missing data I can do a linear
interpolation I can use the prior days
data I can do a Brownian Bridge which is
I just do a Monte Carlo between them I
could do a regression base I can use
regression to project changes from one
on to change is another that's usually a
whole other lecture I give on how to do
missing data now you got that lecture
for free
all right that's all you need to know
it's not only lecture it's it's a very
hard homework assignment but uh how
frequently to update my data
some people update their covariant
structures daily I think that's an
Overkill we update our data set weekly
all right that's that's what we do and
that I think that's Overkill but
tell that to my Regulators
um and we use daily data weekly data
monthly data we typically use daily data
some firms may do it differently all
right
all right
here's your exponential smoothing all
right
remember I usually uh measure covariance
sum of x i minus X Bar times y minus y
bar divided by n minus 1.
what if what if I stuck an Omega in
there
all right and and I use this calculation
instead
with the denominator
is the sum of all the omegas you should
be thinking finite series all right
at least when I you have to do a I was a
decent master and I wasn't a great math
student and when I found when I was
studying this I'm like wow all that
stuff that I learned it actually finite
series who knew who knew that it
actually used it all right so I take
this and let's say I'm working backwards
in time so today's observation is t0
tomorrow uh yesterday's observations T1
T2 T3
so today's observation would get
and and stay let's assume for the time
that the that this Omega is on the order
of 0.95 just it could be anything all
right so today would be 0.95 to the zero
one all right divided by the sum of
omegas tomorrow be 0.95 divided by some
of the omegas the next day would be 0.95
squared divided by the sum of the omegas
9 5 cubed and gets smaller and smaller
all right
when you're using 0.9 for example if you
use 0.94
99 of your weight will be in the last 76
days
76 observations I shouldn't say 76 days
76 observations so there's this notion
that the that the impact declines
exponentially does that make sense
the reason that people use this pretty
commonly but what scares me about it
somebody stuck these fancy transitions
in between these sites anyway is that
here's uh here's my standard deviation
with a rolling six fourth window
and here's my standard deviation using
different weights
and the point I want to make here it's
an important point
my assumption about my weighting
coefficient has a material impact
on the size of my measured volatility
all right
now when I see this and this is just me
and there's no there's no Finance or
statistics theory behind this anytime
the choice anytime an assumption
has this material an impact
bells and whistles go off in Sirens all
right red lights flash be very very
careful
now you know lies damn lies in
statistics see you tell me that tell me
the outcome you want and I'll tell you
what statistics to use that's what
that's where this can be abused oh you
want to show high volatility well let's
uh let's use this you want to Show Low
volatility let's use this see I choose
I choose to just take the simplest
approach
all right and that's that's that's me
that's not a terribly scientific opinion
but that's what I think
all right
versus weekly percentages log changes
units
just like uh dollar yen
interest rates you know am I long or am
I short and am I long or my short if I'm
long gold I show it as a positive number
I'm a short gold in my position Vector I
show it as a negative number
if I'm long Yen and yen is measured in
Yen per dollar
then I show it as a negative number if
I'm long Yen but my covariance Matrix
measures Yen as dollars per Yen point
zero zero zero zero nine four whatever
then I show it as a positive number all
right
it's just it's it's just like physics
only worse because it'll cost you real
now I guess physically be worse because
you get the units wrong you blow up
right this will just cost you money
I've made this mistake I've made the
units mistake
all right uh we talked about fixed
income
all right so that's what I want to cover
from the from the the bare bone setup
for VAR now I'm going to skip the
historical simulation and go right to
the Monte Carlo because I want to show
you another way we can use covariance
structures
it's going to happen two or three more
times
somebody did this somebody made my
presentation cute some years ago and I
just it
all right
see there's a lot of meat in this
presentation that we don't have time to
get to
another approach
to doing value at risk is rather than
use this parametric approach
is to simulate the outcomes
simulate the outcomes
a hundred times a thousand times ten
thousand times a million times and say
these are all the possible outcomes
based on my simulation assumptions
and if I have ten thousand let's say I
simulate ten thousand times
and I have ten thousand possible
outcomes for tomorrow and I wanted to
measure my value at risk at the one
percent significance level
all I would do is take my ten thousand
outcomes and I would sort them and take
my hundredth worst
put in your pocket go home all right
that's it
this is a a different way of getting to
that order statistic
all right it lends a lot more
flexibility because I go and I can tweak
the way I do that simulation I can relax
my assumptions of normality I could I
could do a I don't have to use normal
distribution I could use a t
distribution I could do lots and I could
tweak my distribution I could customize
it I could put I could put mean
reversion in there I could do all kinds
of stuff all right so another way we do
buy at risk
is we simulate possible outcomes
we rank the outcomes
and we just count
if I've got if I've got the 10 000
observations and I want my five percent
order statistic well I just take my my
500th all right
makes sense it's that it's that simple
wow I don't make it seem like that
simple because it actually gets gets a
little messy in there but that's when we
do Monte Carlo simulation we're
simulating what we think is going to
happen all subject to our assumptions
all right and we run through this Monte
Carlo simulation simulation method using
sequences of random numbers coined
during the Manhattan Project is similar
similarity gains a chance you need to
require you need to describe your system
in terms of probability density
functions what is what type of
distribution of this is this normal is
it t is it chi-squared is it f all right
that's the way we do it
so quickly how do I do that
I have to have random numbers now
they're truly random numbers I'm
somewhere at MIT you can buy I used to
say tape but people that use tape
they'll give you a they'll give you a
website or you can get the Atomic decay
all right that's random all right
anything else
is pseudo random
what you see when you go into Matlab you
have a random number generator it's an
algorithm it probably takes some number
and and takes the square root of that
number and then goes 54 decimal places
to the right and takes those and the 55
decimal places to the right
multiplies those two numbers together
all right and then takes the fifth root
and then goes 16 decimal places to the
right to get that it's some some
algorithm
true story before I came to appreciate
that these were all highly
algorithmically driven
I was in my 20s I was taking a computer
class I saw two computers they're both
running random number generators and
they were generating the same random
numbers and I thought I was at the Event
Horizon
all right I thought I thought that light
was bending and the world was coming to
an end all right because this [ __ ] can't
this stuff can't happen all right
it was happening right it was it was a
pseudonym number generator I I didn't
know I was 24. all right but it's it
anyway
um quasimum numbers it's sort of a a way
of imposing
some order on your end your random
numbers
one particular set of draws may not have
enough draws in a particular area to
give you the numbers you want I can
impose some conditions upon that I don't
want to get into a discussion of random
numbers
um
how do I get from
random uniform most random member
generators give you a random uniform
number between 0 and 1. what you'll
typically do is you'll take that random
uniform number you'll map it over to the
cumulative density function
all right and map it down so this gets
you from random uniform space
into standard deviation space
all right
we used to worry about how we did this
now your software does it for you all
right I've gotten comfortable enough
truth be told I usually trust my random
number generators in Excel in Matlab all
right
so I kind of violate my own rules I
don't I don't check I don't but I
most I think most of your your standard
random number generators are are are
decent enough now and you can go
straight to normal you don't have to do
random uniform and and back into random
normal you can get a normal you can get
it distributed any way you want
um
what I do
when I do a Monte Carlo simulation
and this is going to be rushed because
we only got like 20 minutes all right
if I take a covariance matrix
you have to trust me on this because
again I'm covering like eight hours of
lecture in an hour and a half all right
but you guys go to MIT so I have no
doubt you're going to be all over this
all right
all right
extra
all right
let's take this out of here
I can Factor
my covariance structure
all right
I can Factor my covariance structure
like this and this is the transpose of
this
I didn't realize that the first time we
did this commercially
I saw this instead of this and I thought
we'd send bad day to the customer I got
physically sick and then I remembered
a b transpose
equals B transpose
these things keep happening I think my
high school math keeps coming back to me
all right but I've forgotten this and I
got physically sick because I thought
we'd send bad data because I was looking
at this when it's just the transpose of
this
anyway
I can Factor this into this where this
is the this is a matrix of eigenvectors
this is a diagonal matrix of the
eigenvalues
all right
this is this
is the vaunted gaussian copula
this is it I mean most people view it as
a black box if you've had any more than
introductory statistics this should be a
glass box to you that's why I want to go
through this even though I'd love to
spend another hour and a half and do
about 50 examples because this is how I
learned this I didn't learn it I didn't
learn it from looking at this equation
and say oh I get it I learned it from
actually doing it about a thousand times
in a spreadsheet and it sunk in like
water into a stone all right so I
factored this Matrix and then I take
this which is the square root Matrix
foreign
which is my transpose of my eigenvector
Matrix and diagonal matrix containing
the square root of my eigenvalues now
could this ever be negative and take me
into imaginary root land
well if my variances are positive
or zero then that will be a problem
so here we get into this remember you
guys study positive semi-definite
positive definite once again it's
another one of these high school math
things like here it is I had to know
this all right suddenly I care whether
it's positive semi-definite covariance
structures have to be positive
semi-definite uh if you don't have a
complete data set let's say you've got
100 observations 100 observations 100
observations 25 observations 100
observations 100 you may have a negative
eigenvalue if you just measure the
covariances with the amount of data that
you have
my intuition and I I doubt this is the
is that you're measuring with error and
you have fewer observations you measure
with more error
so it's possible if you're using some of
if some of your covariance measures have
25 observations and some of them have
100 observations that there's more error
in some than others and so there's the
POS the theoretical possibility for
negative variance
true story
we didn't know this
in the 90s I
I took this problem to the chairman of
the statistics department at NYU so I'm
getting the negative eigenvalues
and he didn't know it he got he had no
idea he's a smart guy
you have to fill in your missing data
all right you have to fill in your
missing data
if you got a thousand observations
thousand observations thousand
observations 200 observations and you
want to make sure you don't have a
negative eigenvalue you've got to fill
in those observations which is why
missing data is a whole other thing we
talk about
all right I again I could spend a lot of
time on that and I learned that the hard
way I learned that the hard way all
right but anyway so I take this square
root Matrix
if I pre-multiply
that square root matrix by row after row
of
normals
all right I will get out an array
that has the same covalent structure as
that which I started with which I
started
I've got some is another story here I've
been using the same eigenvalue I believe
in full attribution I'm not a clever guy
I I have I have not an original thought
in my head and whenever I use someone
else's stuff I give them credit for it
and the the guy who wrote the code that
did the eigenvalue decompass this is
something that was translated from
Fortran 4.
all right it wasn't even wat five we're
talking four it's a there's a dichotomy
in the world
there are people that have written
Fortran
and people that have it I'm guessing
that there are two people in this room
that have ever written the line of
portrait anyone here
just saying
yeah did with cards or without cards
I didn't use cards that was
see you're an old timer because you use
cards
and Eric
the the punch line is I've been using
this guy's code
and I can show you it's like The Lone
Ranger I didn't even get a chance to
thank him
because he didn't put his name on the
code
I mean like on the internet now if you
do something clever on the Quant news
groups you're going to post your name
all over it I've been wanting to thank
this guy for like 20 years and I haven't
been able to anyway some diving divided
code that's been Transit let me let me
show you what what this means
all right here's some Source data
here's some percentage changes
just like we talked about
here's the empirical correlation
of those percentage changes
all right so the correlation of my
government tenure to my AAA 10 years
0.83
to my double A 0.84 all right you see
this all right and I have this
covariance Matrix
which is the the the the correlation
Matrix is a scaled version of The
covariance Matrix
and I do a little bit of statistical
Ledger domain
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
take the square root of that and again I
I'd love to spend a lot more time on
this but we just don't suffice to say
I call this a transformation matrix
that's my term this Matrix here
is this if we had another hour and a
half I'd take the step by step to get
you there the proof of which is left to
the reader as an exercise all right I'll
leave this spreadsheet for you I'll send
it to you I have this metrics this
Matrix this Matrix is like a prism
I'm going to pass white light through it
I'm going to get a beautiful rainbow
all right let me show you what I mean
so remember that Matrix this this Matrix
I'm going t
remember my Matrix is 10 by 10 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10. all right
ten Columns of data
10 by 10 correlation Matrix
let's check
all right 10 by 10.
now I've got row vectors
of
sorry uncorrelated random normals
all right
so what I'm doing then
is I'm pre-multiplying
that transformation matrix
row by row by this each row of
uncorrelated random normals and what I
get
is correlated random normals
so what I'm telling you here is this
this array happens to be 10 wide
and a thousand long
and I'm telling you that I started with
my historical data
and I only let me see how much data I
have there
a couple hundred observations of
historical data
and what I've done
is once I have that covariance structure
I can create
a data set
here
which has the same statistical
properties
as this
all right
not quite the same all right I can it
can have the same means and the same
variances
all right that's what Monte Carlo
simulation is about I wish we had
another hour because I'd like to spend
time in this is one of these things and
again I didn't when I first saw it it's
like oh my God I I felt like I got the
keys to the kingdom when I and I did
this manually they don't want a
spreadsheet didn't believe anyone else's
code did it all in a spreadsheet all
right but
what that means
quickly let me just go back over here
for a second
I've got
700 I happen to have about 800
observations here
all right historical observations
what I did was I happened to generate
a thousand samples here
but I could generate ten thousand or a
hundred thousand or a million or 10
million or a billion just by doing more
random normals I could generate
effectively when I'm generating here
is synthetic Time series
that have properties similar
to my underlying data
all right
that's what Monte Carlo simulation is
about the mean means and the variances
and the covariances of this data set
are just like that now
again true story when somebody first
showed me this I did not believe them so
I developed a bunch of little tests
and I said let me just look at the
correlation
of my Monte Carlo data
versus my original correlation Matrix
so 0.83 0.84.85 0.85 0.67
0.81 you look at the corresponding ones
of the ram of the the random numbers I
just generated
0.81.8 2.84.84.64.52
0.54 versus 0.52 0.18 versus 0.12 0.51
versus 0.47 71 to tell me why they're
not spot on
sampling error
the more data I use the closer it'll get
to that if I do a million I better get
right on top of that
that makes sense
so what I'm telling you here
is that I can generate synthetic time
series now why would I generate so many
well because I remember I care what's
going on out in that tail if I only have
100 observations and I'm looking
empirically at my tail I only got one
observation out in the one percent tail
it doesn't that doesn't tell me a whole
lot what's going on if I can simulate
that distribution exactly I could say
you know what I want a billion
observations in that tail now we can we
can look at that tail
all right
if I have a billion let's say I'm
looking at some kind of normal
distribution you know I'm circling it
out here I'm seeing
all right I can really dig in and see
what the properties of this thing are in
fact this can really only take two
distributions and really it's only one
but that's another story
um
so what I do in Monte Carlo simulations
I'm simulating these outcomes so I can
get a lot more meat
in this tale to understand what's
happening out there there's a drama
quickly does it not drop off quickly
that's that's kind of what it's about
so we're about a time I normally I we
just covered like four weeks of material
all right but you guys from nyt have
complete confidence in you I say to the
people who work for me I have complete
confidence in your ability to get that
done
by tomorrow morning
um
questions or comments I I know I've I've
you're sipping from the fire hose here I
I fully appreciate that
um
so those are examples when I do this
with historical simulation I won't
generate
these Monte Carlo trials
I'll just use historical data and my my
fat tails are built into it all right
but what I've shown you today is we
developed a one asset
VAR model
then we developed a multi-asset variance
covariance
model and then I showed you quickly in
far less time that I would like to have
shown you is how I can how I can use
another statistical technique which is
called the gaussian copula to generate
synthetic data sets that will have the
same properties as my source historical
data
all right
there you have it oh you know oh [ __ ]
please please
all right and for me one of the coolest
things was actually being able to apply
so much of the math I learned in high
school and in college and never thought
I'd apply again one of my best moments
was actually finding a use for
trigonometry
all right I I thought if you're not an
engineer where you're going to use it
all right where you use it seasonals you
do seasonal estimation and what you do
is you do fast Fourier transform
because I can describe any seasonal
pattern with a linear combination of
sine and cosine functions and and it
actually works I have my students do it
as an exercise every year I say go get
New York City temperature data and show
me some linear combination of sine and
cosine functions
that will show me the seasonal pattern
of temperature data and when I first
realized I could use trigonometry
it wasn't a waste of time
I'd still pull the coordinates I still
haven't found a use for that one but but
but it's there I know it's there all
right go home